あっえっこにーちゃん外れ雪のです今日はまずでやばいっすよあの僕のところにとある
ものが届きました
こちらですこの箱をなんとなんとですねベイブレードの作者さんからの贈り物らしい
です
じゃーん
開きますパワー
big the 回フード流れ出始め今回は
回数の魔女してはいけない
それはベイブレードの作者さんがくれた大切な大切なプレゼント安打
始め
今回は開封の場合はお預けだ普通に開けますさすがにいただいたもんなやしませんよへ
へーじゃあめちゃくちゃ嬉しいですし何が入っているでしょうか失礼します
4手紙が入っています今日は何が彼の跡地貴文と申します
いつも動画を楽しく拝見しておりますありがとうございます5月にアップされた景勝今
と昔のベイビーデートはどちらが釣れるのか大変面白かったです
実はバースト賭博てず間にもメタルファイトシリーズがありますコメント欄にもメタル
ファイトもぜひ遊んでくださいといった書き込みを見かけました
そこで肇社長にもぜひ遊んでいただきたいと思い別にあったメタルファイトのサンプル
のいくつかを送らせていただきます
ほんの一部になって申し訳ありませんがぜひメタルファイトを主としてみてください
これからもベイビーレイズとこの後本編をどうぞよろしくねっ
私さんありがとうございます入って受けて今回目アルバイト日ベースの原因酒作者の
跡地さんから
ベイブ冷蔵いただきました本当にありがとうございます本当にありがたいですその見た
せていただきます
桜乾が入ってるんだデッキセットだねこれで戦えるのかな
パッと黄色な金色のベイブレードと後ブースターですね
あの僕食器のベイブレードと今やってる
レベルとバーストやってるんですけどもその間にあるメタルファイトに関してはもう
アニメも見てないして実際にベイブレードやっそんでもないんですよ
全くわからないんですちょっと見ていきましょうこれ何が入ってるんだろう
うわっ
2つ2つ2つ出せるのスポーツの中にシューターが入っています色が山丸べたのあっ
たらこういうことですよね
こっちはバイヤーの方です続いてこちらもうなんかベイブレードが3つ入ってるのか
なぁよし
ひとまず3つは完成しました右からサイバー軽いをポイズン逆カウンターへスコルピオ
です裏の特徴的なんですよね全部で微妙に違うんですよね後ろが
galaxy ベガ c 作ってみましょうこちらはギャラクシーぺー画質です後ろ
からバーなんて多分攻撃タイプですねサー様こちらでヘルケルベクス
色が完全に黄色です
ふう ok 完成黄金に光るベイブレードヘルキャラ dx です
まあ前か後ろがすごいかっこいいなぁ割と時給タイプですねこれはたぶん何か特殊な
ラバーグリップと様々なのがありますさあなにはともあれ
まわしてみました果たしてメタルファイトがどれくらいの威力を持つ桁ちょっと気に
なるんだよ暑い中1更新
いいね
ね
うわああああっ鳳凰
そこで入ってあげてめっちゃダサいパーソンで見たんですけどもう一発一発が
めちゃくちゃ強いです
やっぱ金属で戦ってるかどうかな夫が重いし当たっただけですと日がめちゃくちゃ強い
では俺様のベイベーのファーストたいメタルファイト are you doing
最長三大トメファイト今やってる強かったそう
なんかこいつらでちょっと合わせてみようと思いますメタル入れ先に出させてください
壊れるって判断が悪くこっちを先に家ます1回戦目はこちら
持久戦でいきましょうこっちがバーストでこっちがメタルです a 会社目
32まあ go off
rar
me
れた覚えないとダメだぞ
てます音が音がヤバイ
マイルは庇ったり頑張ってるんだ
潔白な w ん
音がかっこいい
いいいいっ
に解説に書いてね攻撃バトルといきましょうか
すいーというは55しくっ
ああああああ
ええええええ
いややばいきてるきてるきてるくれよ
あああ最後はこちら
帝王三脚でデザイナーのレイヤーなんですけどもう持久系でつながっております詐欺
勝率高い
継承生のこいつらでいきましょう321号
おっ
いけ
終わるかてるのって
ええええええ
レーザー水は映像以下にすれば
エガー
ええええええ
しています